- Dear Journal, it's me Doug.
- I may not be the President,
- Yeah.
- Quiet!
(upbeat music)
- On Nickelodeon in the '90s,
I was the voice of Doug Funnie,
Roger Klotz, Ren, and Stimpy.
What a decade.
(upbeat music)
I put a tiny little bit of my own self
into each character.
- [Interviewer] Give me a Doug Funnie.
- Hi everybody, this is Doug Funnie.
Uh, I got such a crush
on Patti Mayonnaise.
I was pretty much like
that at 11 years old.
I used to fantasize a lot, you know,
I could entertain myself for hours.
- [Interviewer] And what about Roger?
- Hey, you're the biggest loser I ever saw!
(laughs)
He was based on a bully
that used to bother me.
- [Interviewer] How about Ren?
- Will you shut up, you fool!
Else I shall kill you!
- [Interviewer] And Stimpy?
- Hey Ren, I picked a nose goblin.
I picked it myself.
Pew!
- [Interviewer] Do you
still entertain yourself?
- I'm sick of myself.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] You also
do Futurama, Philip J. Fry.
- Man, all this constant
exposure to radiation
is making me thirsty.
Shut up and take my money!
I sounded just like that when I was 25.
I was all whiny and nasally.
If I broke a string on stage, you know, it's like,
ah man, what am I gonna do now?
- [Interviewer] And Dr. Zoidberg?
- Young lady, bring me a
sandwich from the dumpster.
And leave the maggots on it.
Wooooo!
(claws clapping)
I'm struggling.
- [Interviewer] Professor Farnsworth?
- Good news everyone.
I don't want to live on
this planet any more.
- [Interviewer] Zapp Brannigan?
- She's a beautiful ship, alright.
I'm gonna fly her brains out.
I'm very fortunate, really
lucky that I can do what I do,
and I want to just keep coming to work
until they tell me don't come in anymore.
And as a final word, mwah!
Goodbye.
(upbeat music)